this is not the Great Depression let me
say this one more time we are not living
in times even close to the Great
Depression not even remotely close to
the Great Depression here's why you hear
a lot of experts well this close to
Great Depression let me tell you what
we're going through here's what the
prediction is yes we have fourteen point
seven percent unemployment today yes 30
million people apply for unemployment
but but during the Great Depression
people didn't have money to eat food
during the Great Depression millions on
top of millions of businesses were going
out of business no one was being bailed
out the only thing they did during the
Great Depression is a minimum wage of a
quarter which FDR came out with and
Social Security which FDR came out with
Social Security was for the elderly
folks and then minimum wage to get four
to start paying their people more and
change it from 69 hours a week that were
working at Ford to making it 40 hours a
week being full time that's some of the
things that took place not at three
trillion dollar bailout not a $1,200
check being sent to everybody not a
unemployment check just being a pro left
there and be sent to everybody not all
these you know checks that are being
sent to small business owners or these
major companies that are being bailed
out that's not happening now Pelosi is
talking about the second round of
stimulus that's coming out no this is
not the Great Depression by the way it
may not even be 2008 because in 2008
Bear Stearns went out of business
Lehman Brothers you you had you had
countrywide went out of business you
have companies that have been around
you're talking about
wamu that was a 330 billion dollar
company no five according to Fortune
magazine was bought by cheese for 1.9
billion you talk about a lot of
companies went out of business we're not
seeing that today why am i sharing this
with you here's what I'm sharing this
with you a lot of people last few days
have called me and they've said things
like oh my gosh Pat I feel so bad they
took that Judy Mike of it's interview
down and what do you think you'll be in
this and you think you're being labeled
I'm like no not at all it's just a video
that was taken out yeah but I feel so
bad for you I'm like don't feel bad for
me I'm the luckiest man alive I got a
great family I'm doing good I'm living
in a country that gives me freedoms I'm
running businesses I have great friends
around me I'm still healthy you know my
kids still love me I am very lucky man
you do not need to feel bad for me but
what is happening today
is a lot of the media is making people
feel bad for themselves and no one does
good in their lives when they start
feeling bad for themselves you're not
productive when you're feeling bad for
your so because nobody wants to follow
somebody who's feeling bad for
themselves who does no one does there's
a the last dance there's a part in the
last dance where the the Bulls are
facing off the Pistons and this is the
game seven one Scottie Pippen starts
having anxiety attacks and he says he
was not feeling good but he starts
having anxiety attacks and he doesn't
show up in the seventh game the Bulls
are supposed to beat the Pistons he
doesn't show up the Bulls lose Jordan
comes back he says that entire offseason
he worked on Pippins mindset to make him
tougher next year they go into playoffs
they're facing the Pistons it's it's the
last game that they're about to beat the
Pistons he goes for a layup
boom Rodman thousand and shoves him in
the audience Pippen is on the ground for
few seconds
everyone's watching him Pippen got up
and the Pistons even said when Pippen
got up he showed no hurt you can't hurt
me when I shot the free throws they beat
him was game over they didn't even shake
their hands you know what the message
was you can't hurt me Pistons you cannot
hurt me they won the championship six of
them six to three Pete's is what the
Bulls did you cannot hurt me
we need that message today not
everything can hurt me oh my gosh I'm
afraid no one follows anybody that's
showing hurt I'm not saying you're not
hurt I'm not saying go be a robot yes
sometimes I'm on my cell phone my car
and I have some emotional conversations
with myself yes sometimes I'm alone and
I see my kid that's worried about now
going back to school spending time with
his kids yes I know that happens I'm not
expecting my kids to be robots I'm not
expecting my wife to be a robot I'm not
expecting my employees here to be robots
we have feelings we have emotions but we
don't show hurt because when you show
hurt other spirits enter your body I
don't want any of those spirits to enter
this body not the bad David family and
it shouldn't enter your body what for
fear fear fear fear fear fear fear
stop it media already Stu
much look when I was a kid I was living
in Iran and I was always worried always
worried what's gonna happen to our lives
I love my sister I love my mom I love my
what if something happens to us I don't
want to live my life without the people
I love the most you think about those
things and the system I had to help you
overcome this was very simple all my
relatives who were going to Austria they
got their visas a green card they go to
Austria or France or Germany to
eventually come to America all of them
it would have these parties and we'd go
to him and I was sitting as oh my gosh I
know we don't have our green card or
visa or your own I can't wait till when
they go to America I can't wait to one
to go do I can't wait for us to have
that kind of freedom I can't wait for it
I am so looking forward to it in my mind
I was living in the future you know the
saying that they say if you live in a
past you will be depressed if you live
in the future you'll have panic attacks
if you live in the present you'll be
calm today is a not a bad time to live
in the future a little bit what do I
mean by this I'm looking forward to
Christmas even though it's seven months
from now I'm looking forward to
Christmas you have no idea how much I'm
looking forward to Christmas I'm looking
for because we had a great Christmas
this last you maybe wonder I'm looking
forward to 2021 I'm looking forward to
the next 10 years I'm looking forward
I'm looking I'm optimistic I am looking
forward now oh my gosh I can believe
what's gonna happen no no I'm looking
forward to the future you ought to look
forward to the future it'll spin and
confuse that emotion of victim feel
sorry for me oh my gosh I'm scared I'm
hurt
now it'll flip it see what it does to
you start talking about it with your
wife and kids your husband your brother
sister boyfriend girlfriend mom dad
everybody you know I'm excited about
twenty twenty-one I'm excited about that
they'll be confused they said what are
you talking about are you now watching
the news mom I'm just excited about the
future mom test it out call him and do
it today and see what happens people
will be confused I am excited about the
future can you tell I'm excited I'm
genuinely excited about the future
because this ain't no Great Depression
and even if it was we overcame the Great
Depression today people are being bailed
out we're gonna go back to normal very
soon people gonna be weird out weirded
out a little bit
airlines and airports and planes and all
this other stuff some of the industries
are gonna take a little longer to
recover some companies are gonna take
kids because we have not allowed people
to go beyond together so hotel business
anything that's going to be a lot of
people being around each other the
concert some of these things yeah some
of that's gonna happen what we're gonna
go back to normal eventually don't let
these people confuse you that it's just
constant end of the world type of stuff
that gets a viewership but that's not
leadership I'm more concerned about
leadership than viewership this video is
not gonna do that good but I'm telling
you what I believe that we need to hear
it would do much better if I gave you
some bunch of things to be afraid about
ten times more views not solvent four
views I'm solvent for leadership so my
challenge to you is very simple chin up
in post confidence don't show hurt put
things in perspective and lead the
people in your life and eventually
everything will work itself out
you